first zoom meeting and i'm so excited
[ __ ] guys this is great
i was so upset they didn't let me on the
bachelorette so i figured i could just
make one myself do they typically allow
gingers on the bachelorette
there was one there was one last season
how far did she get in
no not five we started dating
and i turned into a worm what would you
do i'm not gonna lie
i would question it at first but
ultimately i'd remember
i'd you should still be a bad [ __ ] even
as a worm right so like
i'm still beijing if i took you home
to meet my parents and my mom was hotter
than me
is your mom's tingle no good answer i
would say
this is a great future to look forward
to okay so brian
so if i put on a dress and it did make
me look fat like i didn't look great in
it
and i asked does this dress make me look
fat what would you say
i'ma say you do look sad but not that
fat i'ma say you look funky fast
with the ph okay i mean like every time
i walk out like dang
y'all she looks funky fat up in this
place what
okay if the boys were to ask you
to go out i said whatever have fun what
would you do
i don't have any boys um if the
situation were to happen
i'd probably just invite you to come
along i have to eliminate brooke
because i told you i'm into guys brooke
i
i messaged you my number just in case i
mean you're really cute
max what the what i'm sorry
got the message before she left wait do
i have to leave nice to watch
oh i thought you got eliminated oh well
then [ __ ] never mind i didn't give
you my number
you called brook you're into guys so how
did brookston wind up on this
just really wanted to be a part of her
experience
second round if i said does this dress
make me look fat and it did what would
you do
i would tell you yeah it makes you look
fat don't you want to go on something
you're truly confident in and love
wearing
the big [ __ ] recognizes a big [ __ ]
bryant would you jump in front of a
bullet for me
definitely i would all ready wow yeah i
might do it like our cool style like we
had to play some action music and i'm
like oh hey and i got shot
i'll be all good yes i worked for you if
we were going to go on a date where
would it be
i'll go to her mom's house she's hotter
than me let's go play best let's go play
basketball you're tall gonna have to
eliminate this round max i'm 6'4
because he tried to hit on my friends
like five minutes ago
so i feel like that's not a great sign i
mean
brook's really cute like i'm sorry she's
very attractive it's hard not to
say something this is why you got
eliminated first round brooke i'm
sorry hannah jesus i'm also you know
interested if you want to
kick them out are you are you trying to
hit on both of us
at the same time i mean i would go on
dates with both of you like i don't see
that as a problem like
who's jonathan jerome my guy what's up
jonathan
jt has kind of seen somebody so like he
might not be available but john is
definitely available
no so max let me let me recap here so
first
you join you join right then you hit on
my friend and me at the same time
and then then and then you bring i mean
my friends are cool
and then you bring in a friend that's
not even single
the first question i have for you
because you aren't here for the other
questions
is what would you do if we started
dating and i turned into a worm
i would help you grow into a butterfly
i'm a worm the rest of my life but you
know we have a great connection
we're totally in love and then i turn
into a worm one day but i have the same
personality
what's your answer to that um
i would put you i would i would set up
your own like little room in like a box
and make it all like luxury like have a
mini pillow
and then a mini head and you know just
make your life great
as a worm still be like faithful to me
and stuff to be honest
no but like i would still treat you well
because i know
nobody else would beyonce or shakira
beyonce yeah
rihanna rihanna obviously why are you
kidding me
rihanna taylor what's the strangest
place you've ever been
i lived in albuquerque for a while
that's a [ __ ] so brian
moe if you unexpectedly won ten thousand
dollars what would you spend it on
i'll probably use like half of it to pay
off my school day because like
i i would like go on the cruise i've
never been on the cruise and i'll
go skydiving so i'm going to have to
eliminate
on this round damn damn
who is the hottest kardashian i want to
say courtney
i have a question for brian yes
how many donuts could you fit in your
mouth at one time
if it's a good day i'mma say four so
tell me are you guys ass or boob guys
yes i'm both
on my shoulders on my shoulders and that
kind of guy
this round i'm gonna have to eliminate
bryant because
i don't have boobs so um i only have ass
morris you were late to the game but now
you've become my fiercest competitor
no i have a question for you so let's
say
we start dating i think some of the
girls you follow on instagram
are too hot tell you that you can't
follow them anymore do you want to
follow them
if if they're a close friend like then
that's that's just sol
like it's not like a close friend it's
just some hot girls on instagram oh well
definitely of course
i was gonna follow them what are you
guys biggest pet peeves when people chew
food with their mouth open bad grammar
bad drivers
no i think i have to eliminate you
because i definitely am a messy eater
and i'm a bad driver
yeah and confirmed she isn't terrible
wait so hold on did i just win wait so
wait
what are you doing you want to go on a
date tomorrow i have a guitar lesson
tomorrow i can do tuesday though
all right tuesday